incredibles one you know I loved your
Incredibles next year they have the
black version coming out it's called the
ice uh so this next person this next
presenter was so convincing as Katharine
Hepburn that Sidney Poitier went to a
house last night for dinner okay
please welcome Academy Award nominee
Cate Blanchett
the categories makeup the artists who
work their magic in this area use a
variety of tools to create miniature
works of art sometimes to enhance the
Noctis features and sometimes to distort
them but always working in the service
of the truth of the film here are the
nominees for achievement in makeup this
year Valli O'Reilly and bill Corso for
Lemony Snicket's A Series of Unfortunate
Events
Keith Bangalore and and Kristin Tinsley
for the Passion of the Christ Joe Allen
and Manuel Garcia for the see inside
and the Oscar goes to Bali O'Reilly and
built also an enemy sees a series of
unfortunate events
this is the first Oscar and nomination
for dolly O'Reilly and Bill Corsa
uh this is an extremely fortunate event
I'd like to thank the Academy for making
my parents so proud Colleen Atwood for
being such a good friend and always
hiring me and inspiring me Brad
Silberling mitch kathleen medusa and
tanya for working so hard and i'd like
to formally apologize to all the actress
for making him look so unfortunate but
it was worth that wasn't it thank you
mister Lemony Snicket please don't write
any more of these books that they're
corrupting our youth Brad Silberling I'm
sorry you did such a good job in this
movie DreamWorks paramount Nickelodeon
Brad Silberling why'd you have to do
such a good job and Jim Carrey if you
weren't so good I wouldn't be standing
up here and I thank you for that I
shared this with you Morgan Valley
everybody thank you